all right now pay attention ss7 in the
sales once this may look like an
ordinary academic poster but you see
here my name on it you actually can't
see that then we get a different camera
angle which means of course that it is
superior we have an introduction section
that one of my supervisors that you see
absolutely everywhere motivation section
equations lots of maths we Ferris Ashley
quite simplistic Matson anybody who
knows what they're talking about would
see that's actually very easy summary I
references and look at what I'm talking
about
and bitching greater than that one thing
that's worth pointing out is that this
is a weird size so this is five feet by
three feet which is slightly bigger than
a zero it's different from zero which
made actually making it in [ __ ] I've
made this in game from the first shop
around lays out kind of interesting
that's create custom size template so
why does America do you think so
strangely like these coke bowls in the
UK these are five hundred mils and in
the UK its focus in the US here it's 20
fluid ounces or clauses as I started
calling them but yeah I'm really pleased
I'm really really pleased to have them
out it looks very professional it just
sort of makes you realize it yeah you
know you are doing real science this is
something that is very specialized you
are a tiny little increment if he were
knowledge that you're trying to push and
you're the person I'm the person who
knows the most about this in the world
about this hypothesis just kind of scary
thought
okay so now I'm beginning to realize
just how big this place is I just said
to Tom meet him in student lounge didn't
know the student lounge well so I just
thought I'd make it up as I went and
find it I'm not sure that's going to cut
it
I found a tongue I can't song alright
yeah good
oh I had to admit I just came here I
didn't know where the student lounge was
I just I just winged it where is it
yeah oh good okay so it turns out that
the student lounge is the most
disappointing thing since the Phantom
Menace fire so we're now gonna go to a
talking the other side of so I'm like I
can almost want to call it a canvas you
know but these huge huge buildings we're
going together slide the campus
including a session on gravity waves so
our first session done Tom nodded off
second talkity was gone so the rest of
that session was quite high up in the
atmosphere that was gravity waves and
trees are a very general topic and we
focus on the stratosphere and basically
rest that talk was on the mesosphere and
also a lot on the southern hemisphere I
really like New Zealand don't they hmm
we're both gonna go to this general the
special general need special general
which is completely nonsensical it
doesn't mean anything and there's no
more information about it but it's the
guy who's in charge of the XPrize is
have you interested to go to and I'm
going to do some work later okay what
are you gonna do this afternoon see some
posters oh yeah this poster session I'm
like a charlie lecture
Verena so we just popped into the cinema
before we go to the session I just like
to make it know that one of the films
used Comic Sans for its titles and it
made me feel slightly sick yeah it was
ah that must have been done for a bet
that's so bad so we've just got in here
for the X prizes tour we were just at
the very front of the line somehow I
have no idea how I managed that and this
place is absolutely huge one side was
right in the middle the stage is right
there we've basically got the best seats
in the house who just noticed there's no
UK on this map look it was that there
were no islands at all apart from this
mysterious Atlanta Atlanta in kind of
structure that's between Africa and
India look at that that's graceful
actually no way to explore and fund
those explorations with the Kings
McQueen's no hundred years ago it was
still the government's in the large
corporations but what makes this most
exciting time ever to be alive as a
scientist as an explorer as entrepreneur
is the fact that the ability we have now
to do this as small teams as individuals
so that was interesting they were
launching a new X PRIZE which was to do
an ocean exploration automated ocean
exploration and there was a whole
discussion including some rather awkward
grilling of the shell representatives it
was sponsored by shell and I think
really quite valid questions are being
asked about flight change there it is
about why shell would want to sponsor
something which is all about improving
understanding the oceans if not to
improve exploitation of ocean resources
yeah we're gonna go get some lunch and
then I think well we might be parting
ways I think you might be doing some
posters and I've been working right
let's go city look at that
skyscrapers
so list isn't shopping because jeans in
Macy's hit like a third of the price
there in the UK and I'm walking on this
bit of greenery which is here for no
clear reason winter walks SF happy that
my Oxford senses are screaming at me for
walking on something that is green my
shouldn't be there's the entrance to
Macy's good lord
so you might well question why I'm doing
touristy stuff in the middle of a
conference given that has already
started well when we left we were
advised to do about fifty to fifty
percent here time on academic side 50
percent of the time doing
cultural stop drinking in the area
that's because as we found in each of
you if you just do science all the time
you just burn out and stuff digital age
from the we just doesn't go in so you
need to take your time out and pace
yourself especially when you're in a
place like this
it's a shame not to
well that was an experience
right so we just chilled out for a bit I
just did someone we'll be doing by the
way not a lot how cute I was doing a lot
I was doing a bit of writing out of some
work and now we're joining the great
student migration to student mixer which
has promised three alcohols possibly
free food so it's most certainly going
to be absolutely packed
okay we just mixed we met we met some
people this is the difference right if I
did that in the UK people would just shy
away like you guys are all about light
you know being out there so we
successfully mixed and now we're going
to go up to like a games showcase stairs
right yeah we're gonna go up to this
games thing which is meant to be digital
games board games and card games but to
do with science are teaching it and
hopefully making friends are some more
lovely people there is but one thing for
it we must descend into the mines of
moria okay so in a statistically highly
improbable move everyone on our tables
won all the prizes wins people on our
table something like that a bunch of 3d
maps copy the game that was the game was
actually the game is about biodiversity
in the Arctic it was genuinely really
really good I've now got a copy so I
might have to do a video on that
together we'll do that I'll be funding
now we need to go and sort some food how
it lasts half of these videos those just
us talking about food
yes yeah I should point out I have two
places yeah will you be going to food I
have to get permission from speakers
before video in their talks so yeah
you're not gonna see very much science
but a lot of this so you know
so we just got back in we had food at
the same bar that meeting yesterday and
yeah it had a really really nice chat
actually the TV who sat next to us just
come from a conference and these two
lovely Canadian people um and actually
catch our names but if you feel watching
if you if you had a conversation about
an English dude teaching you how to
swear in British for example apparently
balland is a word that doesn't made it
out of the UK just yet we learned to
slow a bit in Canadian and one of them
actually said it at boot instead of
about which made me very happy
don't get me thinking of really this
conference doesn't feel like a
conference in the sense there's just
people submitting abstracts it's a like
a cultural experience it's like a
convention you go here and you are a
scientist you're surrounded by other
scientists and you get to meet people
and like you get to talk about really
really nice things that people are
researching like the hydrology stuff
that the Canadian girl was doing but
also like just being able to be in a bar
and talking really quite passionately
about physics and have what distinguish
iodine from Fineman from Dirac in terms
of what they're for processes and be the
best introductory physics courses and
it's it's great but if like a science
convention
it's so awesome it's been really really
great so far but yeah we've got a
relatively chill day looking forward to
tomorrow we're gonna go to the hopefully
gonna go to the Elon Musk talk tomorrow
that might need tickets for not quite
sure but then after that I think we're
gonna go to the California Academy of
Sciences lottery tickets so VIP now that
layer between ten kilometers and fifty
comms announced to you is what we call
the stratosphere and it accounts for
almost the entirety of the remaining
mass of the atmosphere so yeah let's see
if I can remember this or if you want
more bunch of videos with John and I
just talking about stuff then please
comment below make sure you go and look
at that singing playlist of choral music
about Christmas comment below which one
piece is your favorite you know just
have a listen to a few on shuffle